a battle zone on the streets of Culiacan
in Mexico the historic homeland to the
violent Sinaloa drug cartel this is how
the people here protects the son of one
of its famous former leaders in what
authorities are describing as a routine
patrol police found a video Guzman Lopez
the son of the jailed drug kingpin
Joaquin el chapo guzman after his arrest
a battle erupted and for hours fighting
raged
[Music]
families with small children in the area
were terrified and hid from the endless
gunfire several organized criminal
groups surrounded the house with a force
greater than that of the Patrol the
power of the cartel was too strong for
police officers withdrew without mr.
Guzman in their custody to avoid further
violence the u.s. indictment against a
video guzman says the 28 year old had
been involved in trafficking
conspiracies since he was a teenager his
father El Chapo ran what was once known
as the most powerful drug trafficking
organization in the world the 62 year
old managed to escape from high-security
jails twice before being arrested and
extradited to the US in February this
year he was found guilty of smuggling
tons of drugs and sentenced to life in
prison violence is no stranger on the
streets of this notorious city and after
more than a decade of cartel fighting
the Mexican President Lopez Obrador has
promised to try and bring peace here
but the blood-soaked bodies on the road
from this latest viewed are a reminder
of who is in charge in these volatile
areas in Burma she'd Sky News